pflanzen sind laut der fahne manko so
intelligent unter intelligenz versteht
er die fähigkeit probleme zu lösen
der italienische botaniker manko so
trifft mit seiner these auf jede menge
skeptiker genaues zu seiner these jetzt
bei klicks um science-fiction klingt
wirklich ungewöhnlich intelligente
pflanzen stimmfarbe marcuse ist davon
fest überzeugt seiner meinung nach
können pflanzen gezielt probleme lösen
dazulernen und sich situationsbedingt
verhalten sogar bereits gelerntes
könnten sie wieder abrufen und erneut
sich dementsprechend angepasst verhalten
pflanzen haben aber kein gehirn wie
tiere oder wie wir menschen sie haben
auch keinerlei organe die solche daten
verarbeiten könnten diese
offensichtlichen tatsachen und fehler in
dieser these locken unheimlich viele
kritiker an aber man crusoe hat seine
these praktisch geprüft und auf die
fehler untersucht die pflanze mimose
musste dafür öfters auf den boden fallen
bei den ersten kollisionen mit dem boden
machten sich die blätter der mimose ganz
klein wie ein igel der sich zum schutz
zusammenrollt nach einigen stürzen
lernte die pflanze dass sie keinen
schaden nimmt und stoppte den
schutzmechanismus für stefan kruse ist
das ein aussagekräftiger lernprozess der
pflanze bestärkt wurde er durch die
tatsache dass nach einigen monaten der
versuch wiederholt wurde und dieselbe
pflanze schon beim ersten sturz auf den
mechanismus verzichtete sie lernte also
seiner these nach nachhaltig dazu
mimosen zeigen ganz eindeutig
gedächtnisleistungen auch ohne gehirn so
der botaniker stefan uhlmann kurse
indem es kürzlich veröffentlichten buch
von manko so die intelligenz der
pflanzen beschreibt er weitere pflanzen
die für ihn ein problem lösen das
verhalten aufweisen
die lima bohne ist für viele millionen
willkommen das futter sobald die milben
anfang an ihr zu fressen sondern sie ein
sekret ab das noch viel penetrante
milben unlock die dann die anderen
milben auffressen
der amerikanische mehr sinn feuer geht
zb auf seine umgebung wachsen seine
verwandten neben ihm ist da eher
zurückhaltend mit seinem wachstum und
der lässt in anderen genug raum zur
selbstentfaltung fremde pflanzen schenkt
er dann wiederum keinerlei beachtung und
wächst einfach drauf los man könnte
sagen dass sie sich rücksichtsvoll
gegenüber ihren artgenossen verhalten
und asozial gegenüber fremden jetzt
denken wir mal ganz frei das würde doch
heißen dass es rassismus unter pflanzen
gibt na ja zurück zum akku so
kritiker halten die these von den
botaniker für sagen wir mal und
glaubwürdig der verschobene biologe
richards von so parallelen zwischen der
these und einem kühlschrank thermostat
heran und sagte einmal es schaltet das
kühlsystem ein sobald eine zuvor
definierte temperatur überschritten ist
man könnte sagen das thermostat trifft
eine entscheidung aber die wenigsten
würden behaupten dass diese entscheidung
irgendwas mit einem freien willen zu tun
hat zitat ende
manko so fordert am ende seines buches
das anpflanzen rechte einräumen sollte
demnächst müssen wir dann wohl für
unsere pflanzen auch noch formulare
ausfüllen spaß beiseite
in der schweiz gibt es tatsächlich in
der bundesverfassung festgesetzte
regelungen die sogenannte würde der
kreatur der artikel 120 besagt dass
sowohl der mensch als auch seine umwelt
von gentechnik geschützt werden müssen
im rechts vollzug spielt die würde der
kreatur bei pflanzen faktisch keine
rolle so die geschäftsführerin der
eidgenössischen ethikkommission ariane
willem sind das war doch jetzt mal ein
wirklich sehr ungewöhnliches thema
pflanzen die vielleicht denken können
ein weiterer sehr spezielles thema
erwartet euch im video hier oben die
präzisions medizin zu app und zum block
kommt ihr hier unten und was glaubt ihr
klappen die blätter der mosel nur nicht
mehr zusammen einfach weil es das so
viel stress nicht mehr möglich ist oder
denkt er an der these könnte etwas
wahres dran sein es gab übrigens auch
schon mal in den siebziger jahren ein
buch sehr interessant das geheime leben
der pflanzen und dazu hat stevie wonder
ein ganzes eine ganze platte gemacht ein
album ein doppelalbum also übrigens
tolle musik diskutiert unten in den
kommentaren was ihr denkt haben pflanzen
eine seele ein gehirn haben sie ein
gemeinsames leben
es gibt ja leute die reden ja sogar mit
pflanzen also ich bin gespannt auf die
diskussion bis dann bleibt dran